Republicans and Democrats differ significantly about the causes of climate change,
its seriousness, and what ought to be done about it.
85% of Democrats compared to 34% of
Republicans in an October CBS News poll
say global warming is caused mostly by
human activity. In an NBC News/Wall
Street Journal question from December,
71% of Democrats, but only 15% of
Republicans said climate change has been
established ad serious and immediate
action is necessary on it. In the Pew
Research Center's survey on political
priorities that inquired about 18
possible priorities for President Trump
and Congress, partisans differed more
about climate change that any other
issue. 67 percent of Democrats but only
21 percent of Republicans said it should
be a top priority this year. Although
differences are deep, there is some
agreement among partisans on producing
domestic energy from different sources.
Majorities in both parties agree that
more emphasis should be put on solar and
wind. A plurality of Democrats and a
majority of Republicans wanted to put
more emphasis on natural. Gas can
Republicans and Democrats come together
on climate change? Let us know in our
poll. Also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.